if I'm doing an accent that's unusual I
have to find a voice that really works
that I can latch on to and then I can
sort of develop it from there it's
tricky with the royal family because
they all do sound sort of terribly tear
there like that and your fingers that
really how they talk like that all the
time The Adventures of Priscilla Queen
of the desert
well the script was sent to me I read it
I absolutely loved it I had not long
been out of a couple of TV shows so it
wasn't that I was looking specifically
for things that were different but the
idea of something that was quite
different was very appealing to me I
then went in and had a meeting with
Stefan Elliot our director it wasn't
really an audition and he said how would
you feel about doing this would you be
uncomfortable I don't know it's big Ruby
great and then I was offered at I desert
holiday let's pack the drag away you
take the luncheon to you I'll take the
ecstasy there are two characters I
suppose the character of Adam he's so
sort of over the top and so kind of
pushy and obnoxious and irreverent that
all the energy in a way goes into into
that character and then the energy
that's in the other character and
Felicia the performing drag queen is all
about the dance moves and the
choreography
[Music]
I was dance captain on the film so I was
in charge of rehearsals with Stephan and
Hugo and they did not learn their steps
as well as they were supposed to him I'm
not really a dancer so you know
everything everything I did I had to
learn we did a lot of research we went
to a lot of drag shows we got introduced
to lots of drag queens and one of the
things that Stephan wanted to do was in
the last day of rehearsal we were going
to do our camera tests and makeup and
wardrobe tests and the plan was that at
the end of that day we were all gonna go
out that night in Sydney to some clubs
in full drag and just sort of cast us
out into into the world for public which
we did and that really was a you know
eye opening experience for everybody we
didn't perform we just got drunk very
clever
cheers girls and congratulations Mitzi
darling you did it one lap of the Broken
Hill main drag in drag the whole thing
was a funny story was about turning up
in these towns like Broken Hill and
Kings Canyon and various towns across
Australia where certain towns folk were
prepped that a film was coming but they
didn't really know what it was and they
wanted to get a lot of reactions from
locals so quite often the locals were
told okay our main characters are gonna
sort of come walking down the street and
you guys are gonna watch and they would
sort of put the cameras on them and
you'd see these people just seeing these
drag queens for the first time country
towns that had not seen anything like
this before this is in 93 as well we've
got to remember so there's some pretty
great honest reactions by by some locals
what are you all looking at the village
people asked me to go on tour with them
in drag it was a work opportunity that
came up after that film I didn't take
them up on it funnily enough of course I
was really then came to just keep doing
what I wanted to do which was to play a
lot of different roles LA Confidential
one of the first films I did after
Priscilla was Ella confidential and
everyone kept saying I was it cuz Curtis
saw Priscilla
and Curtis never saw Priscilla he never
wanted to say Priscilla east until the
you know even till the day he passed
away he still never saw Priscilla which
I was kind of thankful for because he
may not have cast me as it actually had
he seen Felicia a jolly good fellow
yeah
a Stensland the party's upstairs
concern you the great thing about that
film I mean obviously the script was
really wonderful but there was a book
that James Earl Ray had written as we
all know called
LA Confidential that covers an
eight-year period so there's a whole
slew of story narrative that doesn't
exist in the film for me to sort of wade
through tons and tons of backstory about
the character and then also what sort of
happens afterwards and I spent a number
of weeks in LA preparing and we were
driven around by a couple of cops and
taken to some pretty bad areas and told
lots of stories of being a cop in LA and
you just slowly sort of immerse yourself
in all that this should be it the
character that I played in that film was
a new kind of cop I guess 404 Ed's
father had been a well renowned
detective and Ed sort of wanted to
follow in his footsteps but he came from
a more highly educated background and
was on some level therefore treated as a
bit of an outcast in the police force so
in a way he was different to the other
cops I realize difficult give you a
career arrest leave her alone a naked
guy with a gun you expect anyone to
believe that get the
I was always really pleased to be
working with Russell he's so brilliant
and has such a dynamic energy on screen
and he's a Kiwi band I'm English but we
both grew up in Australia so there's a
sort of a connection there he was far
more advanced in his career than I was
but I felt that he you know was very
helpful to me and the scenes with Kym as
well we're really touching because she
was so lovely but the whole thing was a
really wonderful experience because
Curtis particularly our director had
such a great ability to sort of
communicate in them differently to each
active in relation to how that
particular actor needed to sort of
communicate so it really was like going
to film school for me that film he
taught me so much about film acting
memento it's a film that obviously comes
up with me a lot and comes back all the
time and film students talk about it a
lot and a lot of people say to me it
really was the first film of its kind
funnily enough people say to me other
Confidential was the last film of its
kind and memento was the first film of
its kind so I feel really honored to be
part of those two films but Chris Noland
clearly is a genius and his ability to
write that story and make the film that
was in his head as it is I'm it's the
only film I've ever really done I think
we're the finished film is exactly as
the script was I thought you split for
good Wow
things change so I see my name is Teddy
I guess I've told you about my condition
only every time I see it it was just an
incredible honor to be working with
somebody who was so clever and the great
thing about Chris was you know his
ability that really proficient with the
technical side of filmmaking as well as
the emotional journey of each character
and being able to sort of communicate
with us so that was also a real lesson
in filmmaking working with him
there were 25 or 26 tattoos we didn't
see all of them all the time so it was
only a few times that you actually saw
them all applying these tattoos we sort
of had transfers essentially but it took
a good hour or so to get them all on
Sammy Junkers I guess I tell people
about Sammy to help them understand
Sammy's story helps me understand my own
situation
Sammy wrote himself a Henderson months
from notes we shot the whole film in 26
days and all that black and white stuff
was scheduled to be the last two days of
the shoot and I was rehearsing those
scenes on my own in my motel room every
weekend when we were having breaks in
between filming and I kept saying to
Erin Ryder our producer I said we're not
gonna get all that in just two days it's
just it's a lot of stuff I'm doing cuz
I'm folding notes and tattooing and on
the phone and there's just tons of stuff
I had to do writing on Polaroids etc and
then in the last week or close to the
last week Erin said we've got a third
day I was amazing with little brain
damage wonderful credibility you know
the truth about my condition officer you
don't know anything
thankfully when Chris my agent sent me
the letter and the script he at the
bottom of it in brackets he said by the
way this all goes backwards so at least
was sort of prepared prepared for that
but the thing was even though it on some
level it felt like gobbledygook as I was
reading it because I got the sense that
things are just all over the place what
I really got and what was really clear
was the emotional journey of the
character and that as an actor that's
the only thing I'm really not interested
in but that's what I need to latch on to
in order to do my job the other stuff
sort of began to make sense more as I
then worked with Chris Nolan and
rehearsed with him and then funnily
enough once it all made sense to me I
then had to sort of put it all away and
let it all go and and then just treat
every scene as if it was a its own
little thing because I wasn't ready to
remember what had happened before or and
clearly had no clue what was coming
afterwards but of course it also made me
really question my own memory I think
back to experiences in my life where I
look at something like a look at photo
and base a memory around that and go I
actually don't really know if that
memory is really true is it so it really
made me question my own memory thanks
Chris Nolan
The Hurt Locker yeah it was a quick
experience wasn't it I was sort of
reluctant to take that on at first and
Katherine asked me to do it and I read
it and went wow and I had a feel the
things going on it's a time in my career
to start doing cameos you know I got to
that point and she really talked me into
it because she really said no we really
want people to believe that you're gonna
be the person we're gonna follow through
this film and of course if we kill you
in the first five minutes then that'll
be great for the movie I said okay as
long as it's great for the movie then
that's great everything looks okay when
I get down there I'm just gonna set up
that bomb suit that I what was so heavy
and we were in Jordan of course and it
was 9 million degrees so it was really
hot in there I remember having a blood
squib inside the helmet which is
obviously meant to go off as the
explosion goes off and I'm running
towards camera and they're setting at
all and sort of was standing there in
the searing heat and was so taken ages
and they're running wire and it's this
long sort of laborious process not
complaining and then it went off by
accident in my face so of course we had
to take it all off and when startled
okay and then of course the second time
in there putting a lot I'm like is this
gonna go what's gonna happen didn't go
off the second time but it went off
obviously on camera when it was meant to
so and then I sprained my ankle so I was
only filming for like three days and as
I finished filming they then wanted to
get on my dialogue so I put the helmet
on we stuck a microphone in the helmet
and I ran down the train track that I
was sort of running on and I went over
on my ankle and then oh you all right
well we got the dialer that's great
that's a wrap on guy everyone fantastic
guy thanks very much and I'm on the
ground going oh my god on a plane and
went to Toronto and started traitor
and by that point my ankle was like this
I was Hurt Locker
yeah it really hurt a lot
the King's Speech : and I got in very
well we've been friends for a while and
he's just the most delightful human
being is so wonderfully articulate and
eloquent and his lovely funny stories so
I just love being around him which was
great because the dynamic between us is
is tough and it's delicate and it's
quite sort of entangled in lots of you
know family history so it was a complex
relationship too
get right I think and obviously I'm not
carrying the film like he is by any
means but but it was important that that
relationship was right I've been
terribly busy doing what
King King it's a precarious business
these days where's the Russians are with
cousin bill hell you're being dreary I
always have to start with the voice I
feel like I have to find the voice and
then I'm off and running a little bit if
I'm doing an accent that's unusual I
have to find a voice that really works
that I can latch on to and then I can
sort of develop it from there
so to play a real person if you've got
an audio recording or something it's
absolutely priceless
I played Houdini I played Andy Warhol
that played Edward the eighth I've
played other people who are real but
aren't in the public eye so we don't
really know them
per se of course when you play and he
Warhol you've got tons of stuff to view
when you're playing Houdini there's
really only audio recordings and the
sort of slow black-and-white or sort of
super speed it up like I might stuff
with him I can't really tell
so you works cut out for you a little
bit more but obviously with King Edward
his speech his abdication speech is
there online you can hear it so it's
fascinating it's really fascinating if
ever I delve into someone who's existed
before Mildred Pierce well I'm about to
work with the lovely Kate Winslet again
pretty much exactly ten years on from
doing that wonderful show with Todd
Haynes that was just a delightful
experience my agent called me and said
Todd Haynes and Kate Winslet they're
doing Mildred Pierce for HBO I said just
say yes just say yes they said well
they'll send you the scripts I'm like
yeah yeah sure just say yes it's gonna
be great you don't do this very often
mrs. Peirce no I should say I don't
I'm honored he made an exception mrs.
Peirce I mean it was fantastic on a
number of reasons the script was great
Kate was great Todd was fantastic HBO
were really wonderful but I was in a
great apartment in New York I only
worked three days a week so it was in
summer well leading up to summer so
everything about it was really a dream
job you know I went to work and had sex
with Kate Winslet alot kind of complain
about that I still don't know what you
do Monty
oh I don't know truth I guess my
character was pretty well realized and
developed in the script there was no
doubt about it he was quite the charmer
you know he was a CAD but he didn't come
across as a con man per se and there was
something sort of gently broken about
him and it all felt really clear on the
page if I can get what I need just from
the script then I sort of don't want to
go too far outside of that obviously
they had made Mildred Pierce as a film
back in 1930 something another I don't
know I had a look at that but then it it
it just it wasn't helpful so I let it go
quite quickly I read the book as well if
there are historical characters of
course yes I'm wanting to listen to
recordings and look at photos and don't
never but it's also about finding your
own truth in it I think whatever that
means so you're not mimicking too much
Prometheus it's very cool being part of
the alien world it's also even more cool
to get to play Peter Weyland I mean the
guy who kind of created a lot it wasn't
so cool having to wear five hours of
old-age prosthetic makeup hello friends
my name is Peter Whelan I am your
employer you've reached your destination
I am long dead I would get up at two
o'clock in the morning I would be driven
to work and I would start makeup at
three o'clock in the morning and I'd be
ready by 8:00 and I could film with me
till 2:00 in the afternoon and then I
was done and I only did about 15 or 17
days or something on that the tricky
thing about their character was I had to
wear this sort of metal exoskeleton
thing as well which meant I couldn't
really sit down properly I said just do
this and go let me know when you're
ready okay I'll just wait here oh no no
I don't want a drink I'm fine thanks
there was one day where I whinny and did
all the makeup got to my room when they
came in one head said we're just running
a bit behind already this morning we'll
get to you shortly we'll let you know
okay well an hour went by and another
hour went by and they kept popping their
head in and saying we're sure we're
gonna get to you you know and about one
o'clock they went so it's up to you
you could probably take all this off or
we might get to you what do you think
and I'm but this point I'm atrophied
frozen to the spot and I don't think I
filmed that day what was more difficult
was the hour that it took to get the
makeup off fade the reason why I really
cast me was because he wanted to see a
younger Peter Weyland as well there's a
scene where Michael Fassbender puts on
the special goggles where he gets to
talk to Peter Weyland who's sort of
cryogenically sort of having a big rest
and then through the goggles we enter
the world that Peter Weyland is dreaming
that he's in whilst being cryogenically
frozen or asleep and that world it was
going to be young Peter Weyland on a
fabulous lot yacht with all these lovely
lovely ladies in the Caribbean or
something like that Michael Fassbender
would appear and we'd have this
conversation and Ridley couldn't find a
yacht that he liked and then they wanted
to build a yacht and they couldn't
afford that or whatever happened and
they said we'll eventually get to that
scene don't worry and in the end they
went well we probably don't need it it's
just fine to have Michael with these
goggles on and hearing him talk and you
just understand that he's talking to
Peter Whelan I could have just cast a
hundred year old guy instead of me but
I'm very happy to have played Peter
Weyland and I would do anything for
Ridley so that's okay also just working
in 3d with 3d cameras what was funny
though it was Ridley coming up to sort
of because he would have to wear his 3d
glasses at video village watching
play back and then he would come up to
you and give you a direction with this
crazy 3d glasses on and then you
remember that he should throw them down
bloody things I am entering with any of
the sort of villains that you play you
get to the heart of where it started why
wires are caring you know what the
initial intentions were and if someone's
got a chip on their shoulder and then it
just sort of develops and develops and
develops where somebody just needs to
get revenge or needs to feel like they
have a place in the world that's great
stuff to play because are they a villain
or are they just kind of out of kilter
and they then just get carried away with
themselves Aldrich Killian I'm a big fan
you've worked my all the chileans a
young man who's quite a science nerd but
somebody has really rejected from
society and through the brilliance of
his innovation and invention is able to
create something that enables him to
kind of morph into the most perfect
version of himself and comes back a kind
of a better mess-up supposedly a better
man you know pepper the Greek so we go
from one extreme to another which was
really quite fascinating and obviously
people have seen the film and they know
how it turns out
it's not that I actively went I'm gonna
do my fight scenes in Birkenstocks but I
just if my feet are not on camera then I
want to be comfortable okay and I
remember Robert say to me a human burger
sucks
I said yes they said I've never done the
same with anybody in burgers us a little
and a fight scene and I said well it's
hot in here and I you know the boots are
uncomfortable and stuff so so yeah
thanks to Birkenstock for my comfy
acting shoes then my acting shoes how
dare you suggest they're anything less
robert broke his ankle in the middle of
that film because he had to do a stunt
where to jump from one platform down to
another platform and be on a cable and
they wanted to rehearse and he said no I
don't need to rehearse it and he jumped
in the guy holding the cable wasn't
quite sort of ready or something and he
landed hard and he broke his ankle so
the film sort of shut down for like five
or six weeks that's actually the second
film that I've worked on where the lead
actors broken their ankle Adam Sandler
broke his ankle on bedtime stories but
on the weekend he was playing basketball
with his nieces and nephews and broke
his ankle so I don't know if it's me the
innocent I've done lots of television
when I was in my teens and in my 20s I
did two television shows in Australia
that were both went for four years her
long-running TV shows I learned a lot
and really great to work on but not the
quality really of the shows that are
being made these days but I still a you
know I'm an old-fashioned guy I still
prefer making films just because of
one-off thing and it's there up on the
big screen and to be able to encapsulate
a story in an hour and a half or two
hours feels like a greater feat to me in
a way than having the luxury of
spreading it out over five or eight
episodes but that's fine too that's the
beauty of it is being able to do that
but something like the innocence you
know that was fascinating for all sorts
of reasons we shot in Norway we were up
in the fjords and just the most
extraordinary landscape around us
dr. Halvorsen was somebody who I think
also possibly like Aldrich Killian
started off with good intentions and
then things got a little sort of out of
hand he's somebody who has discovered
this really rare genetic condition that
only exists in these Nordic women when
they are faced with a really emotional
extreme kind of situation they as a sort
of a defense mechanism they morph into
the person that they're with
and the doctor that I play it is
somebody who discovered this and and
really wanted to get to the bottom of it
but of course he'd been ostracized from
the British medical community in England
some years before so he felt the
pressure from the outside and I think he
was somebody who you felt was really
sort of coming apart at the seams really
interesting odd kind of story
yeah and an odd character that I got to
play bloodshot my agent had the scripts
and said I thought you might like this
and I read it and I really did enjoy it
and I had a great chat with Dave Wilson
who directs the film and Dave like other
directors that I've spoken about like
Chris Nolan in a way is able to really
straddle the technical side of things
and the emotional side of things
particularly in the visual effects world
and Dave's sort of history with visual
effects is pretty impressive but his
ability to communicate with us about
what the journey of each character was
perfect lovely lovely guy and I just
like the story I thought it was
fascinating and this technology which is
seemingly impossible but on some level
like great science-fiction I suppose
feels close enough that you kind of go
oh maybe it could be real actually
that's kind of inspiring and scary at
the same time at rst we'd rebuild the
most important assets in the US military
soldiers like yourself dr. Emil Harding
runs this organization called rst rising
spirit technologies and he is basically
taking wounded soldiers injured soldiers
or perhaps even dead soldiers and
improving them fixing what's not right
so if someone's lost two pair of legs
through an explosion or someone's lost
their sight or someone's lost their
ability to breathe the breathing
apparatus that he then creates for that
person or the new ocular vision
technology that's implanted into the one
particular character or the new legs
that somebody else receives means that
then they're almost Bionic that they
then have additional abilities beyond
what a normal pair of legs or eyes might
initially give you and of course Vin
Diesel plays ray garrison a soldier who
has died who has now been brought back
to life and through this technology
that's basically running through his
entire body he is now essentially a
superhuman being
do you remember anything VIN like Robert
Downey or Adam Sandler or any of these
kind of guys super famous who have an
entire sort of industry around them I
just always find that fascinating
because I just sneak in to work and do
my thing and then sit in the trailer or
whatever think pop and I set them to do
it all on my own and there's those guys
always have a real kind of entourage
he's a really warm-hearted funny guy and
he's very aware of the Vin Diesel sort
of franchise I get so we had a bit of a
laugh about that at times initiated
sequence I always hope whenever I start
reading a script that I'm gonna read
something I'm not read before and if I
feel that then that's always really
engaging I always just want to be
surprised I suppose even if I'm playing
a character that might be similar to
something that I've done before there
just needs to feel like there's a new
way in for me I guess